[Applaudissements]
il faut du caractère
la résilience pour jouer dans l'ombre
des disparus pour s'imposer sur cette
patinoire
associé à jamais un terrible accident
personne ne va oublier ce qui s'est
produit dit nouvel entraîneur mais en
même temps il faut aller de l'avant
aller de l'avant avec 20 nouveaux
joueurs sur 22
weedon qu'un mood est l'un des seuls qui
était dans l'autobus l'après-midi
fatidique du 6 avril à être de retour
dans l'équipe pour le nouvel entraîneur
qui a déménagé cet été à rome bolt le
défi est énorme
il n'y a pas de manuels d'instructions
pour reconstruire une équipe d'un qui
mineurs de a à z explique t-il il cite
les premiers voyages en autobus vont
être difficiles
tchernobyl times
et ça marche
à rambo est une communauté de 6000
habitants chaque magasin chaque fenêtre
chaque voiture porte encore les marques
de l'accident même les arbres arbore le
vert et le jaune des broncos
quoique les rubans ont un peu pâli
depuis cinq mois
et puis loin des regards du public il y
a ceux qui ont érigé leurs propres
petits monuments dans son cabanon libre
aux gaines accrocher tous les souvenirs
qu'il a pu trouver de son fils d'un psy
qui était l'entraîneur de l'équipe
ça c'était un de ses premiers chandail
dit il malgré la douleur libre au ghana
acheter ses billets de saison des
broncos parce qu'il faut passer à autre
chose je voudrais juste dire à mon fils
que je suis fier de lui et aux joueurs
qui commencent à saison donner le
meilleur de vous même c'est ce que
d'arcy aurait voulu ici laurence martin
radio-canada combo